[Music]
hey you guys welcome back to tombs of
terror
and we're doing another book review
today just like we always do on this
show now the one we're doing today this
is a little bit more of a novella really
that's kind of short this one is called
knight
of the mannequins by steven graham jones
this actually came out in 2020
and i guess this was another one that
wasn't on my tbr list
but it just kept coming up in my
uh recommendations like on amazon and i
kept seeing like other
book channels covering it and uh
that and his other book which i think
they came out the same year which was
called
the only good indians which i've also
heard a lot of really good stuff about
but because this one was so short and
this is the first time that i'm reading
anything by stephen graham jones i think
i might have read some of his short
stories because his name is very
familiar
but so i wanted something that was kind
of like short to see
if i wanted to kind of go whole hog and
read some of his other stuff
even though from everything that i've
heard this one is not quite like
some of the other stuff that he's
written but
i don't know i liked this one enough
that i would definitely like read some
more stuff
of his now the thing about this book is
that it's so
short like i said i think it's only
about 130 pages you can easily read it
in one sitting
it's so short that it's gonna be really
really difficult for me to like talk
about without
spoiling it and honestly when i was
reading the back of the you know the
blurb on the back
it kind of spoils one of the things
anyway
so i really didn't think it was that big
a deal so like i said if you want to
read this
just like usual if you don't want to
know anything about it which as i said
that's the way i like to approach horror
novels i don't really even read the
blurbs or anything
i just like see somebody recommended it
and gives a sentence or two synopsis and
i'm just like okay that sounds good so
and then i just like start reading it
but if you don't want to know anything
anything about it then
go read it it probably will only take
you an hour or two and then come back
and we can talk about it and you know
we'll see what you thought about it we
can talk about it in the comments if you
would like to
so this book is basically it's from it's
in the first person
and we're hearing it in the voice of a
teenage boy
named sawyer so keep in mind if you're
not real into the style the writing
style of this book
it's very much as though you're
listening to
a teenage boy talk you know what i mean
it's almost kind of like
i saw another review that compared it to
like somebody just
you know even like making a youtube
video or something like that where he's
like confessing all of this stuff that
happened so it's very conversational
um you know very off the cuff and um so
if
so if you think it took me a little bit
like a few pages to get
into the writing style you know what i
mean just because it was so
it was so much like a teenager would
talk but after that it didn't really
bother me anymore
so keep in mind that if you don't really
like that type of
you know conversational type of tone
then maybe this knot
might not be uh your thing but because
that's how the whole thing is written
so you would think from the cover and
from
the title it almost kind of seems like
it seems like steven graham jones was
trying to i don't know if i'd
necessarily say he's trying to like
subvert
like b movie tropes because the way that
it was kind of marketed the way that it
sounds
on the back of the book almost makes it
sound like
a slasher which it kind of is
or like one of those b movie like big
monster type of
things or like you know or a town gets
overrun by living mannequins like
tourist trap or something like that
that's
the first thing i thought it was tourist
trap actually which you should watch if
you haven't seen it it's actually really
good it's from the 70s but the book is
not really like that at all as i said
it's sort of like
a slasher but it's kind of a
psychological
thing as well with like some ambiguity
to it
so what you have is that there's this
small town and there's this group of
friends
uh boys and girls and they're all
getting ready to i guess this is going
to be their last summer
um you know after they graduate high
school or or whatever so they're
probably
they're you know they're probably going
to be separating so
you have this group they've been friends
for a really long time now this one
particular summer before the events of
the book
they found an old abandoned department
store mannequin like in a creek or
something in the woods
and for a long time they would kind of
just wag this mannequin around
and play pranks on the other townsfolk
with it that was like something that
they were
really fond of doing but this last
summer um i guess
at this point as i said everyone's
thinking about going off to college or
moving away
and so they're not really thinking about
the mannequin anymore and the mannequin
who is named manny
very uncreatively has kind of been
forgotten about so he's kind of just in
sawyer's garage like sitting on his
dad's old motorcycle or whatever
but sawyer decides that because it's
their this is their last summer together
he wants to pull one last prank
kind of bring the mannequin out of
retirement and pull this one last
prank on uh particularly his friend
shauna who has just gotten
a job at a at the local movie theater
but also
on kind of like the the manager of the
movie theater because he kicked some of
the boys out for
you know sneaking in without paying and
they kind of wanted to get back at him
for that so what they decide to do is
dress manny up like a person uh you know
like you would
and put him in the movie theater and
then just kind of have him sit there and
then they're gonna sit in the back
and you know and watch the hilarity
ensue like when
the manager comes around looking for
tickets or when shauna comes around
and uh you know sees that it's a
mannequin and not a real person and they
think it's going to freak him out and so
they think that's really funny
now what ends up happening so they do
this i love like all the stuff about
where he's trying to
they're trying to sneak the mannequin
into the movie theater which
you know obviously that's kind of hard
to do and they have to sort of cut it
into pieces
you know what i mean like take it apart
cut it into pieces and like put it in
their backpacks and whatnot
and then they have to sort of reassemble
it like in the front row
so they do all that they put clothes on
it and they put it in there so
uh the prank seems to be going
swimmingly uh the usher comes around
to look at this person's ticket
but nothing happens you know as i think
they bought it a ticket but then if they
like put it in his pocket or something
and it looked like the the guy that was
going around checking the tickets like
looked at the lap and they just kept on
going like nothing was weird
and they were like well huh that's
really unusual and they thought that
their prank was kind of
you know gonna go over like a wet fart
or whatever and then
something really weird happens after the
movie is over
the mannequin apparently gets up and
walks out
like a regular person so from this point
forward sawyer becomes convinced
that manny the mannequin has come to
life
and is essentially punishing his friends
for forgetting about him because as i
said they used to take him everywhere
and pull all kinds of pranks with him
so he's kind of like given it agency and
given it life
in his head now not too long after this
their friend shauna the girl who works
at the movie theater
is killed along with some of her family
members in this really horrific like
freak accident like a truck like drives
through the front of their house or
whatever even the dogs get killed
and they're all just like turned into
complete mush
and because of this freak accident he
becomes convinced that manny the
mannequin
is going around killing each of his
friends one by one
and also killing their families like in
revenge
and he even has these other ideas that
manny is going around because i guess
there's kind of a rash in the
neighborhood of
people's um kind of sheds and stuff
being broken into and then
the only thing stolen is you know bags
of fertilizer so he gets the idea that
manny is eating fertilizer and that he's
growing up to like kaiju size
like so he's like a godzilla vatican so
the more the story goes on the more
the scenario becomes more complicated in
his mind
and to him it's logical that because
shauna and her whole entire family were
wiped out
presumably by manny the mannequin he
thinks that
by killing all his friends himself
that he will spare the family members
because to him he figures well you know
it's bad that you know four or five
teenagers have to die but
you know if i don't do this then
manny will wipe out all of their
families and that's even more people so
he thinks he's being a hero so there's
like a thread through there
because there's a thread too about the
for the movie that they see
at the beginning where they first do the
prank it's like some superhero
which is supposed to be like a marvel
movie but he doesn't call it that but
that's what he's referring to
and then it seems like every subsequent
event that's like significant to the
story
has something to do with that movie like
you know shawna was like downloading it
when the truck crashed into the house
you know there's a scene at a drive-in
where it's also playing
so it's so it kind of becomes wrapped up
in his mind that that movie that he's
being a superhero
in a way that he's doing something he
doesn't really want to do or something
difficult for a greater good that's kind
of like what his
thinking is so as i said
the thing about this is that
sawyer pretty much from the outset and
like i said this
this is a spoiler review um so don't
complain i told you that at the
beginning
but sawyer is essentially an unreliable
narrator obviously
or i guess they kind of leave it in
biggest theater i'm not really sure but
um or obviously manny
is not has not grown to godzilla size
and is like wiping all these people out
this is sawyer just making up this story
in his head and using these weird events
happening in the town to sort of feed
into this narrative that he's
constructed
to give him justification for killing
all his friends
presumably although this isn't stated
outright but this is what i got from it
anyway
because he was upset that all of his
friends were going to be
leaving him so i think that's why he
sort of projected those feelings onto
manny like you know we forgot about him
in the garage
and you know he now he wants to kill us
all because
you know we used to hang out he was our
best friend and
you know now everyone's leaving and
forgot about him so i kind of feel like
those were his feelings but he was
projecting that onto the mannequin
because as the story goes on
you know he starts killing like picking
off his friends he starts wearing like a
mannequin
mask uh you know almost like he's you
know doing the work of the mannequin
because he thinks that
if he doesn't do it then the mannequin
is going to kill
more people um i saw this one review
earlier and this was actually a pretty
astute observation i can't remember what
her name was but she was reviewing this
book as well
and she said this actually kind of gave
her the
vibe of like remember that case where
those two little girls like
thought that they had to kill their
friend for slenderman otherwise
slenderman was going to wipe out their
whole families
it's kind of like that but as i said
this is all from
sawyer's point of view even though you
can say oh it's not
all that believable that someone would
come to believe that a mannequin had
come to life
and had grown to giant's eyes and was
going to wipe out i mean
the fact that that it did happen in real
life in the slenderman case albeit
you know those kids were much younger
than this boy is supposed to be supposed
to be
17 or 18 years old but he's obviously uh
got mental
issues so the fact that he just develops
this
really complicated scenario about this
mannequin
just you know what i mean so it is
unbelievable but
in a way not you know what i'm saying i
actually really really enjoyed this book
like i said it
take it took me a couple pages to get
into the groove
of the writing style because as i said
it's very casual it's very off the cuff
very conversational
and it's just like a teenager would talk
so you have to kind of get
you have to kind of have to vibe with it
and it takes a couple pages to do that
um it's kind of short so you don't
really get to know
any of the other characters all that
well um you're basically just seeing
them through
sawyer's perception because he's the one
talking about it also at the end i will
say that
i i think i want to say that they left
it ambiguous that manny wasn't real
um you know that he wasn't really
walking around but in a way they kind of
don't
i mean stephen graham jones i don't know
he doesn't really explain
well then why did sawyer because i think
i remember from the beginning
that it wasn't just sawyer that saw
manny ostensibly
get up and walk out of the theater so it
doesn't really explain
why they saw that or what happened to
the mannequin subsequently
unless he just kind of imagined that
whole scenario i'm not really sure so
they do kind of leave that a little bit
vague
there was kind of a little bit of a
thing at the end where one character you
thought was dead is still alive
um you know so but i didn't really mind
that like some people didn't really like
that
plot twist or whatever but i didn't mind
it but yeah i just this is just a really
fun it's like a slasher and it's funny
but it's also kind of like a little bit
grim and a little bit like kind of
disturbing but
i don't know it's hard to explain it's
just it's just like a really funny
slasher but it has like a lot of
psychological
uh kind of [ __ ] to it too and it's like
you know if you like unreliable
narrators
if you kind of like you know just like a
fun quick
i don't want to say it's kind of a
breezy read you know it's really fun
like i said it's not maybe not what
you're expecting it's not like a
army of mannequins like coming down the
town or anything like that it's not like
that at all it's basically just like
this one
kid and his you know spiraling psychosis
as he
like imagines that this mannequin is
killing these people but
it's still fun and it's still funny it's
like a got a really dark sense of humor
and um it's kind of it's pretty gruesome
it had like some of the kills were
pretty gruesome and stuff like that so i
really uh enjoyed it
and it didn't really take me all that
long to read so if you're looking to get
into stephen graham jones because as i
said he's written several books um
the best his uh recent one was called
the only good indians which like i said
i want to read that too because that's
gotten like a really lot of good reviews
but it's significantly longer than this
one but yeah
so it's called uh night of the
mannequins and um
pretty cheap pretty short so if you
are in the mood for something like that
then uh by all means check it out
and i will see you on the next one bye